at age four i found a garden living
underneath the kitchen floor it was
hiding behind leftover patches of
linoleum on the worn-out floor my mother
was having removed the workmen was busy
when the garden caught my attention my
eyes became glued to the patterns of
embroidered roses blooming across my
childhood landscape I saw them and felt
a sense of joy an adventure this
excitement felt like a feeling to go
forward into something I knew nothing
about my passion and connection to
garden started at that exact moment when
spring arrived I ran so fast through the
house speeding ahead of my mother's
voice I pulled on my red corduroy jumper
and my gray plaid wool hat before my
mother could get her jacket on I cata
pulled it out at the front screen door
and threw myself on a fresh carpet of
grass excited I bounced to my feet and
flipped three more cartwheels before
landing by her side mother deer was in
the garden busy breaking up the soil and
I sat beside her playing with mud pies
in the flowerbed when her work was done
she rewarded me with an ice-cold glass
of bittersweet lemonade and then lined
my shoes with sprigs of mint to cool off
my feet my mother cooked with the colors
and textures of her garden she baked
yams and squash and heirloom tomatoes
and carrots she fed love to a generation
of people with purple hull peas and
greens it seems that during my childhood
the blooms from my mother's gardens have
healed all the way from her halo to the
roots on the soles of our feet in our
last conversation before her death
she encouraged me to go anywhere in the
world that would make me happy since
then I have planted her gardens through
art installations throughout the world
in countries of the people that I meet
now they're aligned in parks and
courtyards painted on walls and even in
blighted Lots off the street if you were
in Berlin Germany you would have seen my
garden at steel vert Design Center where
rosemary and lavender hydrangea and
lemon balm trailed up the glass
elevators to all six floors in 2009 I
planted Philosopher's garden a garden
mural blooming at the historic Frederick
Douglass High School in Memphis
Tennessee this school's garden fed an
entire community and was honored by
Eleanor Roosevelt during the Great
Depression
again in 2011 I planted at Court square
park six entry Gardens with 80 varieties
of deliciously fragrant floribunda and
hybrid tea roses gardening has taught me
that planting and growing a garden is
the same process as creating our lives
this process of creation begins in the
spring when you break up the soil and
start anew then it's time to clear out
the dead leaves debris and roots of the
winter the gardener must then make sure
that a good disposition and the proper
nutrients are correctly mixed in the
soil then it's important to aerate the
topsoil and leave it loosely packed on
the surface you won't get those
beautiful blooms in life until you first
do the work just right when our gardens
are balanced with care we can harvest
the beauty of living a life of grace
in the forests when trees realize
through their roots that another tree is
sick they will send a portion of their
nutrients to that tree to help them to
heal they never think about what will
happen to them or feel vulnerable when
they do when a tree is dying it releases
all of its nutrients to other trees that
need it the most below the surface we
are all connected by our roots and
sharing nutrients with each other
it's only when we come together that we
can honestly grow it's the same for
humans in the garden of hardship in this
garden when the caterpillar transforms
into a chrysalis this involves some
struggle but it's a challenge with a
purpose
without this painful fight to break free
from the confines of the cocoon the
newly formed butterfly can't strengthen
its wings without the battle the
butterfly dies without ever taking
flight my life's work is to illustrate
how to integrate human connectivity into
the garden Gardens are full of magical
wisdom for this transformation Mother
Nature is creative energy waiting to be
born
Gardens are a mirror that casts their
own reflection into our waking lives so
nurture your talents and strengths while
you appreciate all you've been given
remain humble to healing and maintain
compassion for others cultivate your
garden forgiving and plant those seeds
for the future
the garden is the world living deep
inside of you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]